the best part about having your parents
be your parents when they're when you're
on social media as they only thing they
couldn't do is take my phone
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
morning walk talk or morning sitting on
my ass in the car talk
some days are just gloomy not every day
you're gonna wake up and be like I'm
going to dominate the world like getting
into that mindset of being able to grind
through a day that doesn't feel as
awesome or you know getting comfortable
with the uncomfortable I think so much
of on today's worlds
anxiety and unhappiness is around as we
demonize losing that we don't realize
like losing an adversity is the
foundation of success and like
competence and ability like the ability
to grind through a [ __ ] day where
it's [ __ ] raining and disgusting
right after summer you would [ __ ] this
[ __ ] being able to [ __ ] grind through
that 7 8 9 10
your reality
that's good stuff so we need to
talk more about so we've got to clap up
for all the people that persevered
through days that they don't want to
getting comfortable with
adversities is powerful
I have the best day ever
Vayner Nation what's good uh really
excited to do another live episode back
in the office in New York with
one of my favorite families on Earth the
milios are here all four of them that
always makes it the most fun parents
fear for kids to be in situations that
are challenging has destroyed the kid
parents continue to over coddle children
and what what they think they're doing
is helping and what they're doing is
they're signaling to the kid I don't
think you're capable of doing [ __ ]
without my help which then renders that
kid to not be confident a lot of times
kids figure things out and it's the
hardest balance because you sit there
and you want to give your kids more than
you had and you'll have all this
knowledge and you you want to protect
them every every every way and and it is
it's detrimental and we've and I think
that's why people are like oh the kids
are so well grounded because as much as
we did that we we did try to have them
fall when they on their own yeah that
was very important people are struggling
out there with this conversation and
they're blaming things they'd rather
blame Tick Tock and the phone for their
lack of strategic parenting we lack
accountability on this subject matter
from the kids level and the parents
level and I think you for sit in a very
unique place to make a massive impact on
the world on this and I will continue
behind the scenes to encourage you to
make content around this because you can
really help people thoughtful real
conversations about human dynamics
that's how you change the world in a
positive way and I think you have a lot
of credibility in this Arena and are
sitting with a lot of stuff in your head
in your stomach that you haven't brought
out yet and I I hope to see you do that
okay
hey Gary how are you nice to meet you
such a pleasure Ryan how are you great
great pleasure great to see you
everybody labor Day's funny because I
hated school so much
so still to this day I'm 46 years old
and when Labor Day comes around I still
have weird feelings about like being
nervous and upset because my brain still
says we're going back to school comma
the New York Jets are my favorite thing
on Earth so I also get the feelings of
the football season's about to start
though the last decade has been pretty
unbearable so
um and I also really love yesterday like
the Tuesday after Labor Day is one of
the weirdest days of the year for me
it's like this wild hard reset from like
the two weeks that I'm actually calm
because I know everyone's checked out to
I've got to get three months worth of
work done in one Tuesday because we're
[ __ ] back and let's go hard you know
what I mean so it's like it's a very
funny time of year
when I invested in Tumblr I called my
brother and I said AJ Tumblr is going to
be bigger than Facebook and Twitter it's
gonna be the biggest one of them all and
he said why and I said
because Facebook and Twitter you follow
people Tumblr you follow things you're
interested in
and so even back then I was fascinated
by the intra scrap over the social graph
what Tick Tock has tapped into in the
last three years
has completely changed
and will change everything we're all
doing and is the answer to your question
what we need to win on now is creative
that is advertising that is educating or
entertaining and everybody here has to
leave with two things one we need to
actually get into the creative business
and make things that people want to
watch two we need to make it for many
different consumer segmentations and go
up and then see the common ground and
then understand what our brand stands
for based on 37 different consumers
segmentations of relevance once you can
understand the upside down model of how
brands are built because the internet
now rules not the television
then you can really start to understand
what to do
how you been ah awesome awesome it's my
son hold on one second
my man
baby bear I'm gonna call you in a little
bit I love you a friend of mine just
said that his dad picked up his call
every time he called and his dad was a
big executive and like literally from
that second on I'd like if my kids call
I'm I don't give a [ __ ] what I'm doing
I'm picking up dudes honestly I think
that was the coolest [ __ ] thing
because ironically I got a 15 million
dollar year business on making money and
over fish successful yeah I have
contracts left and right I could do
whatever I want but I don't know my
family I made a choice at that moment
that close it down and choose my family
wow
that's a big deal it was the craziest
[ __ ] thing I ever did honestly
looking back like how long was that
happening in your subconscious or was it
very quick
um yeah it was it was probably building
for about two years and it was building
and I got to the point where it's like
okay I'm either gonna I'm gonna be dead
you know so what could you yeah so I
just said to myself like [ __ ] it it's
not worth money I'd rather have the
family and live in a trailer yeah than
to have them
I love it yeah I'm running super late
because I'm enjoying the [ __ ] out of
this I gotta go no my mom
okay I'm blind I'm passionate make that
check I'm cashing it take that chick I'm
smashing it and passing it no cabinet
one my time I'm taxing it close my eyes
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to an
all-new season of coffee and commerce
super excited to be with my co-host and
the legend himself Mr Gary vaynerchuk
there's a guy in the comments right now
saying did uh djt Love Goes stop lying
you guys this is full of [ __ ] he goes
you all didn't hustle you guys got lucky
and I think a lot about the makeup of
that comment and like really believing
in that I'm very empathetic to people
being cynical or like not fully trusting
we live in a very complex world and I I
think it's so practical to be optimistic
and give to others because I I really
think when you do good things happen to
you I just actually think it's very
logical but I was also raised by a an
optimistic mother my father was raised
by a pessimistic mother and he's more
like my friend in the comments here you
guys got lucky it's cynical it's of
jealousy and envy framework and I don't
see that as a bad thing I don't get mad
at that comment I actually have deep
compassion for it I want everybody to
see what just happened dgt love just
said I apologize if I've offended anyone
I'm working the life out of me and I'm
being drained this is something I want
everybody who's been watching to watch I
love this dude and instead of what most
people do on shows like this when he was
coming with the heat early on and some
behind the scenes would have banned him
or the public face that's paying
attention like me what a [ __ ] on him we
come with real conversations and empathy
we had a conversation here for the last
10 minutes and look what it leads to and
this is the civility that this country
desperately needs we have that like of
course people should see the world
differently we come from different
angles different but we have to have the
capacity
to not be in such conflict and that's
how you lead to great things in
organizations in governments in families
and like I'm excited about that this
like made my day this GT love post it
made my day like I always think I'm
right but in the faith of being wrong
I'm like [ __ ] I'm wrong and that
humility and like I love that anyway I
gotta run I'll let you guys go and we'll
talk soon thank you guys don't write
what they done what my duty is Vandal
who need a sample put it work in the
pandemic Julius Randle well through
Tantrums famous for all the you dudes
need to Scandal they selling traumas
drama to scam you who the real Pub
playing strict and they amps from New
York four dollar slices when a solid
slice like a buck 50. in the last like
100 days I've gotten so much more back
into like card life like you know what
Ebbs and flows like you know right like
interests and things that nature and so
it's like it'll be fun to chop up that
cards a little bit nostalgia yeah it's
interesting I'm very like that I've
always been like that like running
through patterns like I'll always be
into the same stuff but it's like Peaks
and valleys right I think so I think
it's very human and like
like the last 60 90 I've been on like
Ebay completed items on cards more in
the last 100 days than the prior Year by
the way be friends
is my destiny because of how I think
about this stuff like all this stuff is
my garage sale pop culture before there
was eBay when there was no logic
literally no data for what I was doing
other than if you went to an antique
store and saw somebody selling it and
you're like oh that's what it's worth I
was garage selling in 92-93 buying Happy
Days board games buying
he I bought a thousand he made man
figures when there was no logic to what
is this worth if anything back to a big
point we made tonight the cat from an
investing standpoint is out of the bag
but if you're really doing it to do it
for real investment I think that there's
still a substantial Delta between the
obvious and the speculation
yeah let's do quick selfies that I'm
gonna get out here five figure six
figure seven figures now we talking
digits she was saying what we said I was
saying I'm a little different pulling up
big body coloring in stars in the
ceiling massages
[Music]
[Music]
I turn